[Music]
on this Sunday night foreign
interference how police believe this BC
property is connected to a covert
Chinese government campaign is this a
national security investigation I really
can't say new details in a global news
exclusive
fighting influenza a particularly deadly
flu season claims another young victim
nothing
seemed urgent enough until it was too
late
building a wall the Republican state
stacking shipping containers along the
Mexico border
plus NASA makes a splash the Orion
spacecraft's successful Landing sets the
stage for a return to the moon the
difference is we're not going for a two
or three day camping trip we're going
back in a sustainable way
global national
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with allegations of Chinese
government interference in Canada this
weekend RCMP officers descended on a
non-profit Center in BC the headquarters
of a group that says its purpose is to
promote Unity within the Chinese
Community but a police Source close to
the investigation says their probing
allegations that include coercion and
threats against community members Ramina
Daya has the exclusive details
is this a national security
investigation I really can't say no
comment from RCMP national security
officers investigating China's foreign
interference activities in Canada
interviews were conducted at the wind
gel friendship society a non-profit in
Richmond BC multiple residents tell us
the mounties were asking about whether
they'd seen anyone in uniforms or
witnessed any suspicious activity I sent
the uh introduced himself and asked me
about it what was going on in this area
there is some
falsifying the passports and the
currency a source close to the
investigation says the police action was
part of a wider probe also underway in
Toronto into a Chinese government
campaign that uses threats and coercion
against community members
no answer at the door Saturday but over
the phone a society director confirmed
police paid a visit Huawei Sue said he
was surprised the police were asking
questions he says he doesn't know why he
also rejected that the building is
linked to allegations Chinese police
stations are operating in Canada
International Human Rights group
Guardian Defenders says it has found
evidence of several secret Chinese
police stations operating in Canada more
than a hundred worldwide it is a very
dangerous example Victor ho former
journalist with Singtao daily Canada's
largest Chinese Canadian newspaper says
the alleged secret Chinese police
stations are a blatant violation of
Canadian sovereignty it is a best signal
that the Chinese government exercising
their power Without Limits and without
any International laws in recent weeks
the RCMP has acknowledged it was
investigating allegations China operates
police service stations in the Toronto
area the Chinese Embassy has rejected
the claims back in Richmond still no
official comment from our CMP as to why
they targeted the wenju friendship
society Romina Daya Global News Richmond
BC
to an update on the surge of respiratory
illness that is taking a tragic toll
this winter is on track to become one of
the deadliest flu seasons for Canadian
kids in over a decade at least 10
children have died from flu related
illnesses across the country and as
Heather York's West explains hospitals
are warning the worst could be ahead
in West Kelowna BC an entire Community
is in mourning nine-year-old Isla Lawson
passed away in late November from an
infection related to the flu an
infection Isla's family believes wasn't
recognized by doctors until it was too
late are the Layla's gone but if by
her passing something can change to help
it doesn't happen to anybody else that
would
mean a lot to my little baby Canada's
national flu surveillance network is
reporting five pediatric deaths so far
this season but that number will soon
rise with more up-to-date provincial
numbers suggesting that at least 10
children have died from flu related
illnesses yes so we should be alarmed
and we should try to do everything we
can to reduce the numbers the concern is
you've had 10 pediatric deaths and this
is still very early in the flu season
and so you know we still have several
more months to go covet flu and RSV have
hit children hard all at the same time
leaving pediatric hospitals struggling
to cope with the worst season since H1N1
first struck in 2009. I think that this
is the busiest I've ever seen it we're
seeing larger numbers in 2009 and
certainly far exceeding what we see most
years at BC Children's Hospital staff
are preparing for the possibility that
single rooms May soon need to
accommodate two sick patients instead of
one the onslaught of illness has already
forced pediatric hospitals across the
country to cancel surgeries and redeploy
staff what I find upsetting is that it's
a vaccine-preventable disease and that
we've had up until now low immunization
rates in children Public Health
officials are urging parents to get
their kids vaccinated against the flu as
soon as they can masking is being
encouraged too while there are signs
that the flu season may be peaking in
parts of the country the virus is still
very much a threat with hospitals
bracing for some very difficult weeks
ahead
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
turning to Ukraine now and renewed
Russian attacks targeting the country's
power grid in the latest strike
iranian-made drones knocked out
electricity to one and a half million
people in the southern port city of
Odessa over the last eight weeks
Ukraine's prime minister says 40 percent
of the country's high voltage
infrastructure has been damaged
Mackenzie gray has the story The to
watch the World Cup in Odessa Ukraine
you'll need to head to a bar like this
running on a generator it's one of the
few places that has any power the light
of the Moon and flashlights the only way
the 1.5 million residents are able to
see at night
the situation in Odessa region is very
difficult says Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski adding will take days
to fix the two power plants Russia
attacked
zielinski blames Kamikaze drones that
Russia bought from Iran the shahad 136
are a favorite tool of the Russian army
and they have a Canadian connection a
Ukrainian Think Tank found ottawa-based
company Talisman Wireless has a part in
those drones the company acknowledges an
antenna they make is being used but they
also say they've never sold any products
to Iran these are not
um controlled Goods right so the
transfer of these pieces of Technology
don't require an export permit the power
is also about impact moot a town of 70
000 in eastern donbass it sustained
heavy Russian shelling that's forcing
residents into heating tents one of the
only places they can charge their
Electronics
has lost power and water at the house he
shares with his mother relying on this
boat outside his front door to collect
rainwater their heating system is likely
the next thing to give out but that
doesn't concern Andre's mother Ali will
stay strong until our victory over
Russia she says the U.S and British
governments both say that the military
collaboration between Moscow and Tehran
is likely to continue with the next big
purchase potentially being Jeff an
Iranian ballistic missile
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa tonight thanks
Max
34 years since a jumbo jet was destroyed
over Scotland a Libyan man accused of
making the bomb is now in custody
their loss has been ever present in our
minds
270 people died when Pan Am flight 103
from New York to London was blown up
over the town of Lockerbie it Remains
the deadliest terrorist attack ever in
the UK at the time the U.S immediately
pointed the finger at Libyan
intelligence operatives and the FBI has
now taken custody of Abu agila Muhammad
Masood who's accused of building the
explosive the only man ever convicted in
the case Abdel Bassett al-magrahi died
back in 2012.
back here at home amendments to Canada's
gun control legislation are sparking
debate the Liberals say the changes
would ban assault-style weapons and keep
communities safe but there's concern and
confusion over what weapons are included
and what the impact the new rules could
have on Hunters farmers and Indigenous
communities Marnie blunt has more
the topic has been one of contention
ottawa's proposed amendment to Bill c-21
gun control legislation that would ban
hundreds of models of firearms in Canada
creating heated debates in communities
they know that they were misleading this
house and in the House of Commons
Thursday Mr Speaker the mission here is
to get guns up the street and
MP Raquel dancho was booted from
question period Thursday after she
refused to apologize for calling a
liberal MP a liar following comments
related to Bill c21 I'm going to ask one
more time
for her to apologize The Honorable
member for
kildon and Saint Paul
she's not going to apologize thank you
so for them to get up in the House of
Commons and say conservatives are part
of the problem when we're setting up for
Canadian Hunters it is a lie
this as the Assembly of First Nations
voted to publicly reject the bill this
week saying it could infringe on treaty
rights
there is also confusion over which
weapons would be banned and conserves
over many hunting rifles being outlawed
NDP leader jugmeet Singh says his party
supports the bill and the aim to keep
communities safer but has concerns over
the amendment we don't want to see any
laws that breach the treaty rights of
indigenous communities those treaty and
inherent rights to be able to hunt and
to provide for their families and live a
traditional lifestyle so those are
concerns we've raised as well as we we
understand the needs of hunters and of
farmers to be able to to continue to do
what they do prime minister Justin
Trudeau says the goal is to take away
assault style weapons and the exact list
of banned weapons is still being worked
on we understand that there are concerns
by the hunters and and Farmers that were
going after their shotguns and rifles we
are not and that's what we're going to
make sure with fine-tuning of the
legislation the topic will be before the
standing Committee on Public Safety and
National Security again this week as
members will be debating whether or not
to call back some of the witnesses
who've already been before the committee
Murray blunt Global News Ottawa
a border wall built with shipping
containers
coming up the new front line in the
fight to control the U.S Mexico border
welcome back immigration and the U.S
Mexico border have been political powder
kegs since Donald Trump first announced
he was building a border wall and
Republicans are now resorting to
Desperate Measures to stem the flow of
border crossings in Arizona shipping
containers are being stacked Two by Two
in open areas along the state's border
with Mexico although illegal it's the
governor's final act before he hands the
keys to his office to his Democratic
successor next month Mike drolet has the
story
this is the new front line in the Mexico
U.S border crisis since August Arizona's
Republican Governor has been stacking
shipping containers along the border
work that has continued despite the
federal government which has
jurisdiction over the Border telling
them to stop but with no resolution in
sight activists have now stepped in they
were digging this road and they refused
to stop Excavating until we threw
ourselves In Harm's Way really
um
to get to to block the excavator from
being able to do the work but we felt it
was important to stop the stop the
progress and the destruction
the Border issue has deteriorated over
the past year since October 2021 the U.S
border Patrol reported a staggering 2.2
million migrant encounters at the
Mexican border
it's not any better on the Mexican side
which last week detained over 16 000
migrants over a four-day span and
dismantled their makeshift camps the
migrants who are primarily from Central
and South America had hoped to put
pressure on the U.S to allow them to
enter the country
republican-led Texas for one has
responded to the crisis by sending
busloads of migrants over thirteen
thousand so far to Northern
democratic-led cities like Philadelphia
all the while stoking extreme sentiments
with unproven political rhetoric
when they say every
supporter state
I don't think so
by the cartels the criminals the drugs
the fentanyls the human trafficking as
the political Fight Continues in
Washington pro-immigration critics
continue to argue the ineffectiveness of
the border wall when compared to the
hunger and violence migrants are running
away from
I don't think it's a solution in any way
from the um uh the climate and the
ecology uh point of view from The
Immigrant immigrants are going to find
other paths they're going to continue
coming so it's not going to solve
anything without a solution soon the
desperation among migrants is only going
to get worse microlyte Global News
rent relief starting tomorrow Canadian
renters can apply for a one-time Top-Up
the details just ahead
thank you
if you're a renter you may soon qualify
for a new federal benefit starting
tomorrow people with low incomes can
apply for a Top-Up to the Canadian
housing benefit
Ottawa is offering a one-time payment of
up to five hundred dollars to help pay
the rent families earning less than
thirty five thousand dollars or
individuals who earned less than twenty
thousand last year could qualify for the
payment
every year the federal government gets
tens of thousands of requests under
access to information laws also known as
atip now the vast majority come from
everyday Canadians and under the law the
government has 30 days to respond but
new data shows that Ottawa meets that
deadline just 30 percent of the time our
chief political correspondent David Akin
has more on what critics are calling a
broken system
Federal access to information laws are
key tools for accountability and
transparency and they're not working the
atip system is broken
it's broken by lengthy and unreasonable
delays these delays obstruct access to
Justice experts say
urgent reforms are needed mostly to deal
with a culture of delay delay delay
access delayed is access denied Mr Green
you have six minutes new democrat
Matthew green is one of the MPS on a
House of Commons committee pushing for
changes to the access to information act
so in order to have I think adequate
parliamentary oversight in order to have
public trust there needs to be quick and
efficient access to information as an
illustration of the problem Global News
submitted identical access to
information or ATI requests to a dozen
different government departments back in
June 2020.
only one Department responded in the
legislative timeline of 30 days just one
the finance department National Defense
took 105 days the RCMP took 753 days and
last week the privy Council Office sent
over the records we requested
907 days after we asked for them it
really creates a problem where you know
people aren't able to aren't able to get
the information they need in a timely
way Canada's information commissioner
and independent officer of parliament
has made 18 recommendations to fix the
system including more money and more
staff to process atis combined with a
host of rule changes most of all she
says prime minister Justin Trudeau in
his cabinet have to do better action
speaks louder than words
leaders must ensure that their
institutions live up to the legislative
obligations but it's more than just that
several experts included the information
commissioner say that a working access
to information system helps build trust
in democracy trust in government
institutions and helps weaken the spread
of disinformation but the flip side is
also true a broken ATI system like the
kind we have now reduces trust in
government and makes it easier to spread
disinformation David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
the next mission accomplished a happy
homecoming for NASA's Orion spacecraft
[Music]
it's one giant leap for private space
flight with the help of spacex's Falcon
9 rocket a Japanese startup called
i-space just launched a lunar lander
from Florida it's hoping to become the
first private company to land on the
moon if successful it hopes to deploy
two robotic Rovers one from Japan and
another from the United Arab Emirates
it's making a slow fuel efficient
Journey aiming to touch down on the moon
in April
and while one spacecraft went up another
came down NASA's Orion capsule splashed
into the Pacific today after weeks spent
orbiting the moon wrapping up the first
phase of the armidus program that aims
to see astronauts return to the lunar
surface as Jennifer Johnson reports the
successful mission is one small step and
a plan to boldly go where no one has
gone before
America's new Ticket to Ride To the Moon
and Beyond a splashy ending to an
historic space trip the Orion capsule
part of NASA's Artemis 1 Mission landed
in the Pacific Ocean Splashdown after
over three and a half weeks in deep
space ushering in a new era of space
exploration we go back to the Moon to
learn to live to work to invent to
create and liftoff of Artemis one Orion
carrying three high-tech mannequins and
a Snoopy doll traveled over 64 thousand
kilometers past the moon to analyze how
that affected the dummies and how the
capsule held up under extreme conditions
never encountered before the spacecraft
performed so well that we were able to
start looking ahead at Artemis 2 and
thinking through
how else can we push the boundaries on
this flight artemis's goal is to return
astronauts to the lunar surface this
decade establishing a sustainable base
as a stepping stone for future human
exploration of Mars something out of
Hollywood May no longer be a fantasy in
the years ahead there were seeds on
board and so we're going to be able to
see how the radiation environment that
we just went through affects the seeds
because when we look at going to Mars
we know that we're probably going to
need to grow some crops like they've
done in the movies and on TV the next
step as early as 2024 is the launch of
Artemis 2 a manned flight around the
Moon and back followed by the first
lunar Landing of astronauts with Artemis
3. so we're gonna put the first woman on
the moon the first person of color the
difference is we're not going for a two
or three day camping trip we're going
back in a sustainable way longer periods
of stays on the lunar surface sending
humans to Mars is at least another
decade away but with this successful
Mission the exploration of that planet
by real astronauts is closer than ever
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
and before we go tonight a celebrity
shout out for two BC teens is going
viral
[Music]
Eurythmics singer-songwriter Annie
Lennox shared this video on her Twitter
account saying wowza gentlemen you're
amazing thanks for choosing Our Song P.S
who are you the answer is Nanaimo BC's
hip-hop Duo funkinometry Carlo rush and
Jackson fryer their dancing videos
picked up millions of views on Tick Tock
earlier this year the pair used the
platform to connect with audiences
during the pandemic when they couldn't
perform live
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's
your Canada is the Christmas lights in
bowring park in St John's Newfoundland
and Labrador we love seeing your Canada
so please keep emailing your festive
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching Donna Friesen we'll
be back here with you tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]